Poverty has forced more than 5.7 million
children across Latin America into child labor.
And it’s causing many of them to
drop out of school.
In many major cities all across the region,
these children often
end up working on the streets.
But the streets can be dangerous and
children are left vulnerable
to abuse, alcohol, drugs and gangs.
In Peru, more than 13,000 children
are gang members.
But there is one school in Lima offering
kids an alternative to street life –
through dance.
And so far, they’ve reached
over 100,000 children.
The D1 Cultural Association was founded by
former ballerina Vania Masías in 2005.
Diego Ortega is a hip-hop instructor and
dancer for the program.
He now teaches and trains at
their studio in Chorrillos,
an upscale part of downtown Lima.
But his journey with dance began
on the streets at 16,
when he started performing acrobatics
at traffic stops.
Today, D1 is divided into two parts.
On one side, there is a
dance school and company.
On the other, a nonprofit
organization that offers
free dance workshops for at-risk youth.
But back in 2005, it all started with
street performers like Diego.
Diego used the money he earned on the streets
to support himself and his younger brother
after they were abandoned by their parents.
But he quickly realized it was an
unsustainable lifestyle.
That’s when he decided to
join the D1 dance program
that had recently opened a studio
in his hometown, Pachacutec.
He eventually joined D1’s professional
dance company
and went on to win competitions
across the country.
Today, he regularly teaches free
outreach workshops
at the same studio where he got his start.
The goal of the workshops is to provide
students with an alternative
to street gangs, featuring role models
from their own communities.
Like Diego, students who attend the workshops
have the opportunity
to audition for the D1 dance company.
But the focus isn’t just teaching dance.
The D1 program wants to empower students
and give them an artistic outlet.